munichois avant les vacances je ne
m'éloigne un peu du roman parce que en
avançant dans la vie je trouve que tous
les jours la vie est plus fort ni alors
l'aube steam des grands écrivains bon
bien sûr quand tu leur diras grand livre
relié des mauges est banal ou des lignes
et des trucs des cimes ne sais pas ce
que c'est en désordre voire mais la vie
politique j'aime bien les pamphlets
j'aime venir ici je viens de relire le
journal de claude mauriac récemment va
mal quand même moi j'aime bien ça à moi
en parlant de 10 me et tu as eu le prix
nimier ça c'était vraiment c'était une
des plus grandes joies de s'avouer la
normale 1 oui ça a été vraiment
formidable j'étais un jury magnifique il
est très fier là je le porte vraiment
comme me rassure mais franchement tu
penses pas que la tap choisi la facilité
parce que c'est très bien ce que tu
faisais mon 50 connu une prise signé
avec les honneurs on à vichy dancing
aussi frustré qu'il aurait dû continuer
sa belle mais on dirait vous êtes fous
mon petit garçon et c'est pour ça que tu
gâches un talent ben moi je me laisse
porter un peu aussi par la vie la vie
passe très vite
la télévision c'est le wiels on est venu
me chercher ça s'est fait par un
concours de circonstances dans cette
affaire la télévision je voulais écrire
fait un peu de radio mais bon c'est la
télévision qui est venu je me suis pris
au jeu
je me passionne car chaîne passionnément
la chanson et chaque jour je me dis mais
enfin faire toussaint en effet je pense
aussi à cela mais je ne suis pas
malheureux si j'étais malheureux
j'aurais arrêté
j'essaie de continuer de c'est
impossible j'écrirai un jour on est
toujours virer un jour ou l'autre de la
télévision donc que ça s'arrangera un
autre chaque moment où je rallierai
shalit est une chanson qui devient
esprit là comme ça je préfère la mer
reste
de nos amours que reste-t-il de c'est
beau jour une photo vieille photo de ma
jeunesse
que reste-t-il débit et loup et mois
d'avril des rendez vous un souvenir qui
me poursuit sans cesse bonheur pas les
cheveux au vent baisers volés rêve
mouvant que reste-t-il de tout cela
dites le moi
1 au bord de l'eau comme c'est le soir
tu es parfait